I’m Lauren Caspian, and this
is In The Know.
This is In The Know.
You’re a fu***** god.
Morning everyone.
Ready to have a great show?
People are tweeting
that Lauren’s voice
is making them sick.
What are you talking about?
Using the hashtag
In The Know makes me blow.
Blow?
We partying up in here?
He looks so handsome.
Handsome like a chode.
Michael Tyson.
Did you ever think
in the middle of a bout,
I wish I could just
look my opponent in the eye
and say I am enough?
I do that when I smash his face.
Tegan and Sara.
My girlfriend,
also named Lauren,
looks like me.
Does that make me
an honorary twin lesbian?
Wow.
I’m starting an office frat.
Want to be our first member?
This is not an endorsement
of Greek Life
or its rapey wolf culture.
Woo!
How many horny boomers
could you have in this office
before it’s a fire hazard?
I’m sexually attracted to ideas.
I once got an erection from
reading Plato’s The Cave.
Do you have a therapist?
Oh hell yeah.
Ow.
It’s time
for a racial round table.
Hold my hand, Carl.
Carl, your hand.
I’m a baby.
Damn the man.
Hugh Laurie.
What should we do about
Meghan Markle?
I - I don’t
know that any
action is required.
Do you have the research
for the first guest?
This just says
straight white woman.
Tells you everything
you need to know.